hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
twin peak season 3 part 15 10 things you
might have missed video we explore the
warning if you haven't watched through
part 15 this will contain spoilers so
the first thing is pretty obvious and
it's one that I mentioned but I wanted
to say it again because the guy that we
saw walking in the woods in the scene
where Steven and Gersten were by the
tree was actually mark frost and of
course we've seen a ton of David Lynch
in this because Gordon Cole's played a
big role but this is our first time
seeing mark frost reprise his role of
the reporter who we also found out was a
journalist in the secret history not
clear if we're gonna see him again if
he's gonna play any role but it is kind
of interesting that he has a strange
sort of outfit on I think he's wearing a
pair of Uggs and a winter cap there
that's kind of funny but they also
appears to live at the fat trout so I'm
wondering if there's some kind of
backstory to the idea that he was an
on-air personality and now he's kind of
a weird-looking dude that hangs out at
the fat trout the next thing you might
have missed I know I did on first watch
was that the numbers that we saw
Jeffries put out in the steam for evil
Cooper are actually the same coordinates
on Ruth's arm so we saw the actual scene
where Diane put those coordinates into
her phone and it brought up Twin Peaks
so this gives us an idea that judy is
one of the characters who is at Twin
Peaks or will be at Twin Peaks at some
time the odd part is obviously that
details evil coupe that he's met Judy
before but we don't really know if that
means that Cooper is met Judy before or
if evil coupe as himself has so we're
gonna have to wait and see what that's
all about
the next thing you might have missed was
the motel where evil coupe is at
whenever he meets Jeffries is in fact
the same one where Leland met Teresa
banks so this was brought up by a couple
people and people and they has been
checked that the photos are the same so
what we saw there
that hotel that we saw to tire I don't
know if you call it a motel or whatever
but the two times that Leland met with
Teresa banks in fire walk with me
there's really not much more to know
about it I mean that's where we saw the
ring on Teresa banks and we saw that the
room that Geoffrey's in was number eight
but beyond that the outside of it
doesn't look the same as the inside did
you know I mean the outside looks the
same but the inside doesn't so yeah it's
still interesting to keep in mind though
the next thing you might have missed was
the black-and-white film that dougie
coupe was watching is a favorite of
David Lynch's it's called Sunset
Boulevard I've read that it's credited
as being one of his inspiration for
making movies altogether and this is
where we heard the name Gordon Cole
which sent dougie coupe into action
there and that is where David Lynch got
the name for his own character in Twin
Peaks the next one is about Sarah Palmer
and it's not the only one about Sarah
Palmer
but I was thinking as I was writing
these down and putting it together this
one is really kind of compelling and it
was pointed out by a guy on reddit who
goes by Dumble me Harry and he picked
out the one frame that you can see
pretty clearly here where we see that
one you see the jumping man
Sarah Palmer's faces in there
superimposed I guess you would say so
this is really kind of mysterious we
don't really know that that means that
she's the same person as the jumping man
or that say the jumping man's inhabiting
her or something like that but it's
definitely there so it just points out
that Sarah is more important than she
might have seemed to be but like I said
it's sort of been going in that
direction for a while now of course the
jumping man is a popular character
because he's mysterious in the first
place so their connection doesn't really
I mean if she is the jumping man what
exactly does that mean
so yeah it's an interesting thing though
the sixth thing you might have missed
was that the Ruby scene in the road
house kind of syncs with dougie coops
Fork frying scene the crawling in both
the attention of some viewers and people
positive maybe this was connected and
then a YouTube video surfaced that makes
it look like the two scenes sync up they
look really nice playing next to each
other in the video but if you pay close
attention the dougie scene doesn't start
from the beginning so even though they
may be meant to mirror each other in my
opinion to say that it's synced is a big
stretch there's been a few of these
kinds of videos throughout the season
and the starting point of where they use
the dougie scene here makes it the most
circumstantial one for me either way I
think it appears that her crawling could
be a visual call back to Dougie's but
there doesn't seem to be any extra
thought in the filming or editing to try
to have those sync up as an easter egg
the 7th thing you might have missed is
the mysterious woman who appeared to
unlock the door for evil coup so that he
can enter the room where Phillip
Jeffries was shows up again in the last
frame of the episode the courtyard
outside his room is shown during the
closing credits from a couple different
angles and in the very last scene for
the very last frame you can see her pop
up she's really just lurking there and
she kind of blends in because she's not
moving around but it's kind of spooky
when you look at it as a still photo the
next thing you might have missed was the
floor radio or stereo or whatever you
want to call it the woodsman is sitting
next to in part 15 looks like the same
one that we saw on fire walk with me
when evil coupe asked to see Jefferies
the Woodman in the hall is sitting next
to this box and he flips a switch on the
back that sends some electricity into
the air and all that kind of stuff and
it's basically the same thing we saw
going on in fire walk with me when we
first got introduced to the woodsman way
back when people are asking if these are
the same
woodsman I mean I think they have to be
in a way I think that maybe the
character evolved a little bit
creatively but the first one is kind of
a dream sequence if you think about it
so you know it wouldn't have to be
exactly as it was seen I don't know they
they definitely didn't have the black
stuff on them originally and they are
played by different actors but I still
think that these this concept would be
the same I don't know why there'd be
different varieties of Woodsman the
ninth one is one that I wouldn't have
noticed I actually brightened this up in
the when I looked at it after the
episode and I didn't notice this at all
but the ceiling in the room where
Jeffries and evil coupe meet has the
zach same ceiling as the scene in the
mob zone redditors eb double x double I
posted a side-by-side comparison where
you can't miss it
this leads a lot that could be
speculated on since this is kind of a
interdimensional space where there
meaning most likely and since agent
Cooper was passing through a similar
kind of thing the interior of these
rooms may be there as a hint as how this
is all connected
I've seen people extrapolate a little
bit further and say that these are all
different rooms in the same place I
don't think we could say that for sure
because whenever Cooper drops he goes
inside the window we never see the front
side but either way they put this there
and you can't miss it
if you brighten the image so there was a
reasoning behind that it could be just
because the director himself enjoys a
scene with that kind of ceiling and they
use the same soundstage but it could
also be something else and the last
thing that you might have missed was
what Margaret said now her last scene
was very emotional so it might have
slipped by you on the first watch she
says watch for that one the one I told
you about the one under the moon on blue
pine mount now this could be a couple
different things but what some what's
interesting to me about this is that we
see a moon and the peak a blue pine
mountain a couple of times in the show
and in the second half of the series for
the most part so we saw that on Hawkes
map and we saw that on the piece of
paper that Briggs put in the tube for
the guys to find later that got them to
Jackrabbits palace
now some people are pointing to the idea
that this may point tor
that symbol that a lot of people think
relates to the experiment and this leads
to all kinds of different speculation
like maybe that there may be that she's
talking about Sarah Palmer on the other
hand she says that that watch for that
one the one I told you about that kind
of leads us to Laura Palmer and if
Jack's Jackrabbits Palace is on blue
Alpine mountain anyways you know what
I'm saying like maybe that means that
Laura Palmer may reimburse there under
the moon because it says 253 on 10 1 and
10 2 and this is just I'm just thinking
out loud here but it doesn't say that
it's at the same time of debt you know
what I mean it could be to 53 p.m. on
the first to 53 am on the second so you
know that could be something that's a
hint towards that or it could be as what
people are saying that it could be that
that symbol is shown underneath the moon
in both of these instances and that's
pointing to the fact that the experiment
is in Twin Peaks as well and because
we've seen some imagery that looks
similar to that behind Sarah's face when
she takes it off that maybe this is
pointing to the fact that she is
inhabited by the experiment or if you
want to call her the mother you can call
it that too but you know that's the
thing that evil coupe is looking for at
least that's our best guess of what he's
looking for so yeah so that's the 10
things a lot to think about maybe you
guys will tell me what you think I think
you probably will but yeah the Sarah
Palmer stuff is really kind of a lot of
what people are talking about people
will or I have read some compelling
posts about maybe that she was the one
who was on the phone with Eva coupe
whenever you know impersonating Jeffries
I've also read some compelling stuff
that obviously some people think that
she had the Mothe Frog crawl in her
mouth that's a little bit harder but she
is the one who's age-appropriate for
that but I don't know why she would have
been in New Mexico at the time and then
also that scene with her the way that's
placed in part 2 when we first seen her
at the scene of her watching TV when
she's watching the lie and eating the
but like eating the
water buffalos face a lot of people have
said the sequence of that kind of makes
it look like that is related to the
mother or the experiment escaping from
the glass box so yeah there's a lot to
think about there I can't believe
there's only three episodes left it's
really kind of sad in a way I don't know
I hope the next three are awesome we
only got two more weeks of this but hey
let's watch these before we get too
sentimental I guess please like the
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
make sure you turn on notifications so
you get to find out when my new videos
have been uploaded follow me on Twitter
and my other social media accounts so
that we can interact over there thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon